Hey Nina, what’s up?
Hey Tom, I’m working on a piece
about The Dark Knight Rises and
it’s been forever since I’ve seen it. Can
you remind me what happens in that movie?
Sure. So it’s been eight years since all the stuff
from “The Dark Knight,” and
Gotham is doing pretty well.
Like, well enough that they don’t
need a rich guy dressed like a
bat to throw boomerangs at their problems anymore?
That’s exactly how well they’re doing, and
it’s all thanks to a little something called
the Dent Act. See, Commissioner Gordon lied
to everybody and told them that Batman killed
Harvey Dent, and that because of that,
the police needed to be tough on crime.
So they needed to be tough on crime because
the District Attorney got killed by Batman.
Right.
The fact that there was, like, a
clown army blowing up hospitals and
taking hostages on boats did not convince
people that they should be tough on crime?
I don’t know what to tell you, Nina.
People just love their district attorneys.
I guess.
Like, name the last five district attorneys
that you weren’t simply wild about.
I can’t.
Exactly. The point is that it worked, Batman
stopped being Batman, and Gordon -- Well,
you know how sometimes when you tell an
enormous lie, the best thing you can do is
to write down a damning confession and carry
it in your pocket with you wherever you go?
...No.
Right, Gordon does that.
Okay.
And then meanwhile, there’s this guy
named Bane who’s out here kidnapping
nuclear physicists and setting up
shop in the sewers under Gotham.
That sounds like the sort of problem
that you would throw a boomerang at.
And I can’t disagree with you, Nina.
The problem is that Bruce Wayne is all
messed up. He’s walking with a cane
now ‘cause he ain’t got no knees.
He… ain’t.... got… no... knees. Alright, go on.
He’s got so few knees that he gets
robbed and beat up by Catwoman.
Oh, okay. So Catwoman’s the bad guy?
No, he loves her.
Okay.
So then Gordon gets kidnapped by Bane, but he
gets rescued by a cop named John Blake who knows
that Bruce Wayne is Batman because he saw Bruce
Wayne one time and thought that he seemed sad.
...Uh huh.
Now you seem sad. Are you Batman?
Yes.
That tracks. So John Blake convinces Bruce
Wayne to be Batman again even though he
ain’t got no knees, and Bruce Wayne tries
to convince Catwoman to help him find Bane.
Yeah, but why would he trust her? She robbed
him and then she beat the crap out of him.
Yeah, but he loves her.
Okay.
So Catwoman betrays him.
So Catwoman is the bad guy?
No.
Okay.
She takes Batman to Bane and Bane breaks Batman’s
spine and then flies him overseas
and drops him down a metaphor.
Well, sure. That happens.
And then Bane takes Gotham hostage with a nuclear
bomb that he made out of an old Wayne Enterprises
science project, but first he explodes a bunch of
stuff and then he tells everyone that the police
lied about the death of Harvey Dent and that
there was no reason to be tough on crime at all.
No reason besides the clown
army and the bazooka fights
and the hospital bombings
from the very last movie.
Yeah. Besides that.
Right.
So then Bruce finds out this whole backstory for
somebody that got out of the metaphor that he got
dropped into one time and it sure shootin’ sounds
like he’s learning about Bane, on account of the
character having the same backstory as Bane from
the comics, but it turns out it’s not Bane at all.
The character with Bane’s origin
story from the comics is not Bane?
No. It’s a twist.
A twist.
Yeah, a twist. Like, remember in “Batman
Begins” when the movie told you that a
character had one name, but then twist, it
turned out that they had a different name?
Uh huh.
It’s a twist!
Sure.
So then Batman gets his spine punched
back together and makes a giant jump
out of the metaphor that he’s been stuck in.
Does he get his knees punched back together too?
… and he gets back into Gotham with
hours to spare before the nuke goes off.
The clock is ticking.
Big time. Yeah. So he draws a giant
bat symbol on a wall with gasoline and
then waits around for a couple of hours
for an opportunity to light it on fire.
So… No, you know what? I feel
like if I keep interrupting
every time something doesn’t make sense,
we’re never going to be done here. So Batman
is just lighting the city on actual fire now?
Sometimes in order to save that which we love,
we must first set it on fire.
It’s like when my mom got sick...
Nope. Got it.
So then Batman asks Catwoman for help.
Because she’s … wait, why?
And then they go to stop Bane, but then it turns
out that Batman’s old girlfriend Miranda Tate
is actually in charge of the whole operation
because she is secretly Talia Al Ghul.
What?
It’s a twist. Like remember in
Batman Begins where the movie
told you that a character had one name, but it…
I remember.
And how earlier in this movie, they told you that
someone had one name, but it turned out that...
Right.
A twist is when someone has a
different name than you thought.
So Catwoman shoots Bane with
a great big gun and kills him.
So Catwoman’s the bad g…
Talia crashes her car, she dies, and
Batman winches the bomb that’s about
to go off to the back of his airplane, flies
it out over the ocean and then he dies too.
Oh bummer. Thanks for your h…
Or does he?
F---
‘Cause later on, we find out that Catwoman
and Batman are secretly living in Italy eating
biscotti every day and waiting for Alfred
to show up so they can ruin his vacation.
...is that a twist?
Oh ho ho, yeah. It’s a big one. And
if you think that’s a good twist,
wait until you find out what happens
with that John Blake fella from earlier.
What happens with him?
BIG old twist.
Oh… God.
Yeah, you remember what a twist is, don’t you?
It’s what happens when somebody who you think
has one name actually has a different name.
It’s like in “Batman Begins,” when… hello?
Hello? Nina, are you there? Nina?